earlier the term toxic masculinity was
used so i was wondering um if there's a
distinction between toxic masculinity
and toxic femininity and are those two
things different from let's say toxic
humanity and dark triangle
tristan thank you for the question i
believe you
were talking about toxic masculinity if
you would answer the question and then
rolo people follow up sure i was a
little bit nervous about using that term
because i know how true
yeah but i think that toxic femininity
and toxic masculinity are like the um
manifestation of toxicity when you when
you are too
um
wary i guess of the opposite sex and you
become almost hateful towards them so
toxic femininity women saying i don't
need no man i don't need this i'm i'm a
i'm a boss [ __ ] or whatever like and
then with men it's um is my woman
doesn't need to talk she's you know
she's just gonna be she just needs to
look pretty and clean my house
both of those are stupid it's too much
of one way or the other
do you have a follow-up for this steel
panther song for that's what i think but
i'm no expert no um so toxic masculinity
is [ __ ] um that's number one uh
[ __ ] why well there's there's only
masculinity and there's aspects of
masculinity that are convenient to women
and that are inconvenient to women so
it's if a guy is if a guy is fluffing
his chest and like you know full of
bravado and stuff you might want to see
that on the basketball court you might
want to see that in sports you might
want to see that if your life is in
danger and somebody's like posting up on
him you know the guy can fight right oh
is that toxic well it depends is your
life in danger then i guess it's not
toxic it's only toxic masculinity until
the flood waters start rising and you
need people to come you need fema to
come and pick you up right
so there's aspects of masculinity that
are that are quote unquote toxic but
those are the ones that are inconvenient
to the
imperatives or the
the purposes of of you know for for a
female mindset right so in a gynocentric
feminine primary social order we have
terms like toxic masculinity and it
always defines the same dynamic
masculine dynamic that women got no use
for at that particular time until they
do have a use for it so it's toxic
it's toxic masculinity until
you need the the firemen to go into the
burning building and grab the baby out
of there before it burns up and bring it
out of the building that's the same
toxic masculinity that these guys on
jackass have and they express when they
go and do some really dangerous stupid
stunt right if this comes from the same
place it's just contextualized
differently if women have a use for it
then it's not toxic if they don't have a
use for it then oh man i can't believe
guys are all dogs and pigs like that
that because it plays well and again
it's also it gets clicks and it gets it
gets eyes on the screen if you're going
to go and use terms like that so
femininity as well
toxic femininity what do i have that's
is are you female are you feminine are
you you know young or do you meet what i
need or what's the toxic version of that
well you don't need anything i have to
that you don't need a man i asked this
last night on fresh and fit i said is
one girl i said do you need a man
no i don't need no man but i want a man
right it's like well
men who don't who aren't needed by you
they're not going to be they want to be
needed there's that you talk about how
there's compliments to one another how
that men and women are better together
than they are apart that comes from need
not from one i think they need to feel
needed
yes i think like women women uh
in general generalizing should
understand that when they're with a male
partner it's important that they make
them feel needed even if they don't need
them
just to communicate that's pandering
though that's contrivance
i mean i don't think that it's oh it's
okay i need yeah no it's not if i'm
having a really really hard day and
that's the person that i need to talk to
i could i could survive if i didn't
speak to him or if he didn't you know
give me a background so you don't need
him then
well of course there's a fine line but
if you're asking if you're asking me
would i survive for the rest of my life
without a man the answer is yes i would
um would it fulfill me and would it make
me a happy human being no
so it would be a recipe for an unhappy
life on some level of consciousness
there's a need for that guy then there's
a need so that my uh so that my
well-being will be met my my well-being
my words my well-being needs will be met
okay so he's an accessory then uh tyler
i i mean i feel like you're putting
words in my mouth yeah there's more we
got more can i also say just one last
thing the the definition of toxic
masculinity that you gave uh i think it
was different than what i was describing
so if i can just say maybe i wasn't
using the correct terminology no one can
define it i just did a video on this
yeah no they asked a bunch of university
students there is no definition all
right well tristan there you go
you